- The earthquakes that shook
Turkey and Syria this month
killing thousands,
have fractured the country's
transport networks.
The 7.8 magnitude
earthquake destroyed roads
and collapsed buildings onto roads,
rendering some routes impassable,
and effectively rewriting the
map for some cities overnight.
That's made it harder for rescue workers
to get aid in and the injured out.
But now, aid workers
have a number of technological
tools at their disposal
to find new paths through the rubble.
Here's how mapping technology
could help the rescue
efforts in Turkey and Syria.
Firstly, there's drones.
It might seem obvious,
but drones can instantly
give those on the ground
a real-time bird's eye
view of a disaster site,
helping aid workers identify
the safest or easiest
route through obstacles
and informing them of which
paths are completely impassable.
The visuals can also be used
to help rescuers identify areas
that might not have been searched,
and even potentially spot signs
of life among the wreckage.
What's more, they can be deployed
to try and assess the structural
integrity of a building,
giving rescuers an indication
of whether it might be safe to proceed.
Spain has said it is
sending drones to Turkey
as part of its aid package.
But to get a bigger picture
of how road infrastructure
might have been damaged by a quake,
you need to go higher, much higher.
Enter Copernicus.
The Copernicus Program
is the European Union's
eyes on planet Earth,
and is funded by the Union
to monitor things like floods, lava flows,
wildfires and earthquakes.
In addition to their own sensors,
the group sources high
resolution satellite images
from companies like Airbus,
Maxar and Planet Labs,
and combines them with data and analysis
to create a new map of a
region in under two days.
See, mere hours after the
Turkey-Syria earthquake struck,
the Red Cross activated
the European Union's
Emergency Mapping Service,
and Copernicus began analyzing
satellite images of affected areas.
Through a combination of
algorithms and human analysis,
the group has been able to identify
roads that have been destroyed
and buildings that have collapsed.
That open source information
is then published for all to
see and updated regularly,
giving rescue workers a fresh
map of their surroundings.
But what if you could
predict which areas of a city
were most likely to be cut off
in the event of an earthquake
so you could reinforce those areas
to try and make sure
they remained connected?
Well, that modeling tool
is exactly what engineering researchers
Dr. Ji-Eun Byun and Dina
D'Ayala have tried to develop.
The pair worked with Istanbul's
Metropolitan Municipality
to develop a model for
evaluating which areas
are most at risk of being cut off
in the event of an earthquake.
To do this, they took data on
things like building density,
seismic strength, vehicle
throughput and road layout
to create a heat map, which not only shows
which roads and buildings
might be damaged in a quake,
but also which roads might become blocked
if a building collapsed,
and crucially, which
areas were most at risk
from being entirely cut off
in the event of an earthquake.
The research could also be
used to show where investment
could increase resilience
against earthquakes,
essentially, whether it
would be a better investment
to strengthen a building
or strengthen the the road,
or add more connectivity to an area.
Now, the study was only
published last year,
and the researchers tell me it
takes a lot of granular data
in order for the model to work.
But in the future,
it could potentially be
a tool that cities use
to try and keep a path clear
in the event of an earthquake.
(bright gentle music)